[Musique]
notre invité ce matin c'est Patrick
stéphanini bonjour merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation vous
êtes ancien secrétaire général du
ministère de l'Immigration et de
l'Identité nationale ancien préfet de
région vous avez remis lundi au
gouvernement votre rapport sur l'aide
médical d'État qui a été coécrit avec le
socialiste Claude Évin on va bien sûr
longuement en parler d'abord une
question un peu générale sur ce rapport
vous dites que le dispositif sanitaire
de cette aide médicale d'État est utile
qu'il ne génère pas d'abus mais vous
encouragez dans le même temps un
renforcement des contrôles et le
resserrement des critères d'éligibilité
vous êtes converti à la philosophie
macronisu en même temps euh je me suis
converti au faits et à l'analyse des
faits euh l'ame c'est un dispositif qui
permet aux étrangers en situation
irrégulière d'accéder dans de très
bonnes condition
euh et gratuitement à des soins de
qualité dans un pays où l'offre de santé
est une des meilleures du
monde une fois qu'on a dit ça j'ai
beaucoup lu de commentaires de presse
disant que nous a vu que laame était
conforté je crois que ce qui est
conforté par nos analyses c'est le
principe d'une aide médicale de l'état
pour le reste la façon dont elle
fonctionne nous l'avons qu sur de
nombreux points que je peux énumérer
rapidement si vous le souhaitez d'abord
nous avons découvert qu'il avait une
faille béante puisque lorsque le
ministre de l'intérieur ou l'autorité
judiciaire prennent des mesures
d'éloignement à l'encontre d'un étranger
en situation irrégulière ça n'a aucune
incidence sur son droit à laame ça c'est
quand même tout à fait choquant donc
nous avons proposé que toutes les
mesures d'éloignement fondées sur une
menace à l'ordre public entraîne la la
suppression du droit à la
me et puis sur les les conditions de
délivrance de de ce droit nous avons
fait une série de propositions nous
avons proposé d'informatiser la carte à
l'identique de la carte vitale pour
limiter les fraudes mieux contrôler la
consommation de soins euh nous avons
proposé également de redéfinir euh la
notion d'ayant droit puisque nous avons
découvert que non seulement les mineurs
étaient des ayant droit du bénéficiaire
ça ça n'appelle pas de critique mais que
les majeurs euh et la famille élargie
voilà une famille très élargie puisque
il y a le concubin le le le conjoint ou
le ou le partenaire du Pax mais il y a
aussi une notion étrange qui figure dans
une circulaire qui est la notion de
cohabitant donc nous avons proposé
d'émanciper tous ces majeur s'ils
veulent laame bah ils le demanderont ger
que lesf M absolument et puis nous
souhaitons ça n'est pas prévu par les
textes actuellement ce qui est aussi une
lacune quand même étrange nous
souhaitons que puisque que la me est une
aide qui est accordée sous plafond de
ressources qu'il faut pas dépasser un
plafond de de ressources mensuelles de
de 800 € par mois qui est fixé par le
code de la sécurité sociale ben il faut
qu'on prenne en compte les les
ressources du conjoint ou du partenaire
ou du concubain et rien de tout ça n
n'est fait donc l'ame dans ses modalités
de fonctionnement laisse à désirer et
elle doit être réformée voilà ce que
nous avons dit dans ce dans ce rapport
alors mais vous vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec les républicains qui disent que
cette aide médicale d'État constitue un
appel d'air pour l'immigration
clandestine non non parce que je ne
crois pas que on Vienne en France parce
qu'il y a laame d'abord beaucoup
d'étrangers qui arrivent en France
ignorent tout de l'existence de
laame ensuite on sait qu'un certain
nombre d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière ne demande pas le bénéfice
de laame soit parce qu'ils ont peur
d'entrer dans un processus administratif
qui pourraiit conduire à leur
éloignement soit parce qu'ils en
ignorent l'existence ou que les
formalités sont leur apparaissent ex
c'est pour ça que vous demandez
meilleure communication oui oui oui en
effet mais je ne crois pas que la m soit
un facteur d'attractivité Bruno juste
pardon mais Bruno retaillot il dit
qu'un/art des étrangers en situation
irrégulière cite l'accès aux soins gratu
comme raison de leur migration il a tort
en revanche le l'ame est un facteur qui
favorise et nous l'écrivons noir sur
blanc dans ce rapport le maintien dans
la clandestinité et au fond
si on sort un peu de la technique et si
on prend du recul notre rapport il
insiste sur le fait que un certain
nombre d'étranger s'inscrivent désormais
dans ce que j'appelle la clandestinité
de longue durée la la durée moyenne
d'ancienneté dans les droits à la me je
parle pas de la durée de présence sur le
territoire français mais la durée
moyenne d'ancienneté dans les droits à
laame elle est de l'ordre de 3 ans et
demi et il y a quand même 18 % des
bénéficiaires qui sont là depuis plus de
4 ans et et il y a 5 % des bénéficiaires
qui sont là depuis plus de 10 ans dans
un pays où les occasions d'être
régularisées sont quand même
nombreuses la famille le travail et
cetera dans un pays où la la police
quand elle interpelle un clandestin fait
tout pour l'éloigner du territoire le
fait que on puisse rester en situation
irrégulière en bénéficiant de laame
depuis plus de 10 ans ne ne laisse pas
d'interpeller et et je je crois que le
ministre de l'intérieur quand nous lui
avons remis ce ce rapport lundi j'ai
compris qu'il était conscient de cette
situation est-ce que juste Patrick
Stéphanie est-ce qu'il y a des étrangers
qui viennent en France pour des motifs
familiaux pour des motifs de travail
avec du coup des visas courts et qui
finalement restent en France sont dans
la clandestinité bénéficient donc de la
me mais dont en fait on se rend compte
qu'ils étaient venus pour des motifs
médicaux oui alors ça on le pointe et on
a on a confirmation de l'exist de ce
phénomène de de tourisme médical si vous
voulez ou de
filière puisque on a constaté que le
nombre de ce qu'on appelle les séances
alors les séances c'est un terme de du
droit de l'Assurance Maladie ça désigne
les dialyses les chimiothérapies les
radiothérapies
l'oxygénothérapie bref des thérapies de
soins chroniques lourds correspondant à
des maladies graves où le pronostic
vital peut être engagé assez rapidement
et ce que nous avons constater c'est
qu'un certain nombre d'étrangers arrivve
en France de manière régulière parfois
avec un visa de cours séjour ou un visa
de long séjour par exemple pour faire
des études mais à peine ont-ils posé le
pied sur le territoire français qu' se
rendent dans une clinique ou dans un
hôpital et qu'on constate qu'en effet
ils ont besoin de soins ils ont pas été
dialysés depuis 3 jours donc ils ont
besoin d'une dialyse
et bien sûr on leur accorde ses soins
urgents et ça moi je ne conteste pas et
Monsieur Evin non plus évidemment mais
en revanche ce qui interpelle c'est
qu'ensuite il s'engage presque aussitôt
dans un parcours de soins de longue
durée qui sont des soins lourds des
soins chroniques et coûteux et et nous
nous avons appelé l'attention d'abord
nous avons obtenu la la confirmation de
ce qui était une intuition ou une rumeur
enfin et cetera nous avons des chiffres
précis mais qui était déjà pointés dans
un rapport de de Ligas en 2019
l'inflection générale des affaires
sociales cette surreprésentation de
certains soins est-ce que ça qui qui
sont vous l'AVE les cancers les mais
est-ce que c'est pas un signe un signe
voir la preuve de l'attractivité de
l'aide médicale
d'État c'est la preuve alors je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous c'est la
preuve de l'attractivité des soins
urgents c'est le fait que quelle que
soit votre situation administrative et
et ça ne s'applique pas qu'à des
étrangers ça peut bénéficier aussi à des
Français qui n'ont pas de droit prenons
l'hypothèse d'un Français qui n'aurait
jamais cotisé ou quiurit cotisé de
manière très très partielle il a droit
au bénéfice des soins urg ce qu'on
appelle les so soins urgents définis par
un article le
l254-1 du code de l'action sociale et
des familles et il peut donc recevoir
ses soins urgents alors uniquement à
l'hôpital ou ou dans des établissements
privés à buunon lucratif mais il peut
recevoir ses soins urg et ça c'est ça
qui est attractif au fond le tourisme
médical tel que je le décris qui pose un
vrai problème c'est la rançon de
l'excellence de notre offre de soins la
France est un des pays je l'ai dit au
début de notre entretien où l'offre de
soins est est parmi les meilleurs du
monde et et donc effectivement ça attire
un certain nombre d'étrangers alors il y
a une question qu'on se POS parce que ce
sont des traitements qui sont très
lourds qui sont très chers et et qui du
coup sont sont gratuits alors il pe ces
traitements mais est-ce que du coup les
étrangers ne viennent pas en France pour
recevoir ces traitl non mais je suis je
vous ai dit que dans le cadre des soins
urgents c'est pas c'est pas un sujet
d'ame c'est un sujet de soins urgents et
de ce point de vue-là il est difficile à
résoudre madame nous nous avons pointé
cette difficulté et nous l'avons
documenté c'est que nous avons c'est le
le tableau de la page 53 le tableau
numéro 8 il fournit l'évolution et il
montre que dans le cadre des soins
urgent 2022 l'évolution de ce que
j'appelle les séances ça a été plus
qu'un doublement 118 % de hausse pour
laame dans le cadre de la M ça a été 20
% pour le régime général ça a été + 0,7
%. donc oui il y a une filière de
tourisme médical maintenant comment on
fait pour la casser comment on fait pour
la casser parce que le le la personne
qui arrive et qui a besoin d'une parce
qu'elle s'est pas fait dialyser depuis 2
jours personne ne va enfin il viendra à
l'idée de personne de lui refuser d'être
dialysé mais ensuite ensuite qu'est-ce
qu'on fait alors nous avons posé une
question mais c'est une question dans le
droit français du de l'immigration il y
a un titre de séjour spécial qui est le
titre de séjour pour soins ou pour
étranger malad avec deux conditions la
gravité de la maladie et cetera mais une
autre condition on examine si l'étranger
peut être soigné convenablement s'il
peut accéder effectivement à a des soins
appropriés dans son pays d'origine alors
est-ce qu'il faut pour quelqu'un qui
vient d'arriver en France est-ce qu'il
faut se poser cette question et euh en
fonction de la situation dans le pays
d'origine et et je dirais que de ce
point de vue-là le Maroc ça n'est pas le
Bénin l'offre de soin dans un pays comme
le Maroc ou comme l'Algérie ça n'est pas
l'offre de soin dans certains pays du
Sahel donc est-ce qu'il faut se poser
cette question et en tirer la
conséquence que l'étranger qui vient
d'arriver pour une dialyse on va lui
demander au bout de quelques jours ou de
quelques semaines en organisant une
sorte de rapatriement sanitaire de
revenir dans son pays d'origine en tout
cas nous avons pointé du doigt la
difficulté c'est maintenant comme l'a
dit la première ministre hier au au
ministre de la Santé et auire propos
faire proposition on va y venir sur la
restriction du panier de soins le Sénat
a voté la transformation de l'aide
médicale d'État en aide médicale
d'urgence seront pris en compte selon la
proposition du Sénat en charge la
prophylaxie le traitement des maladies
graves et des douleurs aigues les soins
liés à la grossesse les vaccinations
réglementaires et les examens de
médecine préventive ce qui laisse quand
même un un panier de soins important
pourquoi cette Amu n'est pas la bonne
solution alors d'abord si vous lisez
attentivement notre rapport vous lirez
qu'à deux reprises au moins je crois que
c'est à partir c'est dans la page 20 et
21 à deux reprises au moins nous disons
que nous ne pouvons pas porter de
jugement définitif sur la proposition du
Sénat parce que nous ne savons pas ce
que recouvre le concept de prophylaxie
et de traitement des maladies grav parce
que la notion de soin urgent on sait
bien qu'elle est éminemment subjective
et qu'au final elle est appréciée par le
praticien soit de ville soit hospitalier
et ça ne me choque pas nous sommes sur
un un terrain de de de médecine de santé
c'est normal que le praticien est le
dernier mot la notion de maladie grave
elle est également subjective moi je
sais pas a priori est- que c'est qu'une
maladie grave et puis je peux présenter
des symptômes qui me paraissent bénins
mais qui vont interpeller le
professionnel de santé qui va y voir la
première apparition des des des signes
d'une maladie grave donc je vais prendre
des exemples très concrets
si je suis une femme et que je vais
consulter mon médecin et que je sens
qu'il y a une petite petite boule là au
niveau du sein bah moi je considère
qu'évidemment ça participe de la la
consultation va participer de la prophy
d'une maladie grave qui est le cancer du
sein on va être dirigé pour des examens
complémentaires et cetera et cetera euh
si votre médecin vous prescrit un frotti
vaginal bah je crois que c'est la
prophylaxie d'une maladie grave qui peut
être le cancer de l'ovère si je viens
voir un médecin parce que j'ai un rhume
mais un rhume avec une petite irritation
de la gorge qui commence à ressembler à
une angine bah on sait que cette angine
si elle est pas traitée elle peut donner
un flegment et que l'intervention sur un
flegment ça va être plus grave et plus
coûteux donc si c'est bien ça
l'interprétation qu'il faut donner à la
notion de maladie grave euh moi j'ai pas
de problème à ce moment-là avec
l'amendement du Sénat mais vous voulez
pas que ce soit plus restrictif en fait
c'est un problème de de définition et de
précision vous attendez c'est ça et pour
vous il faut pas le réduire plus ce P
non parce que si comme cela avait été
envisagé à un moment donné on réduisait
le panier de soins au seul soin urgent
alors là ça a un effet mécanique qui est
que tous les bénéficiaires de laame qui
seraient privés des autres soins qui
pourraient plus aller consulter leurs
médecins en ville puisqu'ils auraient
plus les moyens le médecin aurait pas
l'assurance d'être d'être payé au final
mais ils iraient à l'hôpital et la
réalité alors qui m'a beaucoup frappé
dans la dans cette mission c'est que les
responsables de l'hôpital public ils
sont tétanisés à cette perspective parce
qu'ils connaissent la fragilité de la
structure hospitalière française
actuellement l'hôpital français il est
au bord du gouffre il est au bord du
gouffre parce qu'il y a eu un
sous-équipement un sous-investissement
parce que il y a une pénurie de
personnel qui nous conduit d'ailleurs je
le signale au passage à faire venir pas
mal de médecins étrangers pour
travailler dans nos établissements
hospitaliers et et donc voilà pourquoi
la réduction du panier de soins au
panier de soins urgent ne serait pas une
bonne chose et ça nous l'avons dit avec
beaucoup de clarté mais elle a été
envisagée juste Patrick Stéphan
effectivement elle a été envisagée mais
notamment par vous dans dans votre livre
que vous avez publié sur l'immigration
en 2020 vous écrivez il faudrait réduire
le champ de laame aux seules urgences et
aux maladies contagieuses les
clandestins ne devrait pas accéder
gratuitement aux autres soins alors du
coup qui faut-il croire le Patrick
stéphanini du livre de 2020 ou le
Patrick stéphanini du rapport de 2023 et
ben il faut croire le Patrick stéphanini
qui est certes un un bon connaisseur si
je puis dire des questions d'immigration
j'ai consacré une bonne partie de ma vie
professionnelle mais je l'ai fait au
ministère de l'intérieur et au ministère
de l'Intérieur au fond on connaît pas
laame on en entend d'ailleurs
pratiquement jamais parler et et c'est
une chose qui m'a frappé dans ce rapport
et j'ai formulé des propositions avec
Monsieur evvin pour y remédier c'est que
les deux ministères au fond ne se
parlent pas beaucoup le ministère de
l'Intérieur ne connaî de la me que parce
que les étrangers qui viennent en
préfecture demander une régularisation
produisent souvent comme seul
justificatif de leur présence en France
leur carte de bénéficiaire de laame et
quant au ministère de la Santé je l'ai
déjà dit et je l'ai dit à propos des
mesures d'éloignement mais on pourrait
le dire sur d'autres sujets les
conditions d'attribution de laame ne
tiennent absol ent pas compte de de
l'évolution du parcours administratif de
de l'étranger sauf évidemment s'il
obtient un titre de séjour mais pour le
reste si le préfet après un examen de sa
situation oppose un refus de séjour à un
étranger ça n'a aucune conséquence
d'aucune sorte sur son droit au bénéfice
de la M donc quand vous aviez écrit ça à
l'époque c'était quoi c'était une
méconnaissance complète donc c'est le
Patrick stéphanini qui s'est documenté
et qui à travers cette mission a
découvert les les les arcanes complètes
du dispositif si je suis rentré dans les
entrailles du dispositif de laame mais
il était très complet votre livre il
était très précis oui enfin je dois
consacrer je crois trois ou quatre pages
au maximum il a fallu attendre la page
278 pour pour trouver cette r mais mais
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes
sur sur cette position à l'époque
c'était une position un peu à la vavite
en tout cas c'est une proposition
insuffisamment documentée est-ce que
quand quand Bruno retaillot dit que
l'aide médicale d'État n'existait pas
avant 2029 ça c'est factuel mais que
pour autant avant avant 1999 pardon et
ça c'est factuel mais que pour autant il
y avait pas de problème de santé
publique avant est-ce qu'il a pas raison
bah il a peut-être raison ça je encore
une fois je n'étais pas à l'époque un
spécialiste mais les les Bonillo sa
pertinemment que les les flux migratoire
ont évolué de manière radicale en 2000
en 2000 nous
accueillons nous délivrons l'année 2000
nous délivrons 150000 titres de séjour
donc à des étrangers en situation
régulière chaque cette annéelà et nous
accueillons 40000 demandeurs d'asile
l'année dernière nous avons délivré
320000 titres de séjour alors ce sont
des étrangers qui ont un droit au séjour
ils obtiennent un tit donc il pose pas
de problème et et nous avons accueilli
132000 demandeurs d'asile et puis nous
avons un phénomène de mineur clandestin
vous avez vu en lisant le rapport
que le nombre des mineurs dans les
ayants ou dans les bénéficiaires
d'ailleurs de la me pour les mineurs non
accompagnés a beaucoup augmenté alors
j'ai employé le mot de mineur clandestin
c'est une erreur un mineur par
définition ça n'est pas un clandestin
puisque'un mineur n'est pas astreint à
la possession d'un titre de séjour mais
en tout cas le phénomène des mineurs et
notamment des mineurs non accompagnés en
2000 il existait absolument pas de cette
manière-là donc l'ame a été conçu à un
moment où les flux migratoires à
destination de la France était très
inférieur à ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
ce qui est d'ailleurs un vrai problème
et mais ça relève pas de la m et vous
dites que le nombre de bénéficiaires va
continuer à augmenter ah bah toutes les
on nous annonce une augmentation de 10 à
15 % de la demande d'asile pour cette
année ça va se répercuter mécaniquement
sur le nombre des des déboutés le
phénomène des mineurs non accompagnés à
ma connaissance il n'a pas été jugulé en
tout cas c'est pas ce que j'entends
auprès des des présidents de conseil
départementaux euh et j'imagine des
sénateur euh et par ailleurs on sait
parce que c'est parfaitement documenté
que les franchissements irrégul li des
frontières extérieures de l'Union
européenne ont beaucoup augmenté cette
année en 2023 notamment sur la route de
la Méditerranée centrale là qui abouti
en Italie et et on sait que une bonne
partie de ces migrants veulent ensuite
venir en France soit pour y rester soit
pour passer en Angleterre un dernier mot
sur le sujet puisque il y a aussi des
rapports de Ligas qui constatent que les
bénéficiaires de l'aide médicale d'État
consomment en moyenne plus de soins que
les bénéficiaires du système général
classique donc ça veut dire qui
contribue moins mais qui coûte plus au
système est-ce que du du coup il y a pas
un risque d'acceptabilité sociale ou
d'inacceptabilité sociale plutôt de
cette ame bien sûr qu'il a bien sûr
qu'il y a un risque pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce qu'on fait un rapport sur l'aide
médicale de l'état pourquoi est-ce que
le débat est passionné parce qu'un
Français qui a des ressources
relativement modestes qui gagne 12 ou
1400 € par mois il accède à une
couverture de de de soins de très grande
qualité mais il paye un ticket
modérateur le bénéficiaire de la me n'en
paye aucun et dans notre il y a a un
chapitre il y a des développements sur
la comparaison européenne alors nous
commençons par dire que cette
comparaison n'est pas facile parce que
les systèmes institutionnels sont
différents mais ensuite nous
pointons plusieurs singularités de la
situation
française au fond il y en a trois de
enfin il y en on en cite quatre mais les
trois principales c'est que en Allemagne
par exemple le panier de soins de ce qui
est l'équivalent de laame comporte des
exclusions qui sont plus importante
qu'en France et notamment il exclut les
programmes de soins chroniques qui nous
renvoie à notre conversation de de tout
à
l'heure par ailleurs l'entente préalable
en Allemagne existe c'est sur un panier
de soins très important et et enfin dans
beaucoup de pays pas en Allemagne mais
dans beaucoup de pays il y a une
participation
financière du bénéficiaire de
l'équivalent de laame ce qui n'existe
pas en France est-ce qu'éisabeth borne
vous a dit ce qu'elle ferait de vos
propositions moi je n'ai pas rencontré
Madame borne et j'ai simplement lu son
article son interview hier dans le
Figaro j'attends d'avoir les
propositions des ministres de
l'Intérieur et de la santé pour
présenter des adaptations réglementaires
ou législativ nous avons remis ce
rapport lundi au ministre commanditaire
madame firman leobudau n'était pas là je
crois qu'elle était retenue à Dubaï mais
monsieur Rousseau et Monsieur Darmanin
nous ont reçu longuement donc voilà
maintenant c'est à eux de s'emparer de
nos propositions et au gouvernement
d'agir ou ou ou au Parlement après tout
ce rapport il est rendu public il est à
disposition l'essentiel des propositions
que nous avons formulé sont de nature
législative donc on ne réglera pas les
problèmes que pose la me et je vous ai
dit qu'il y en avait et on ne réformera
pas la me et je vous ai dit que c'était
nécessaire de mon point de vue sans
texte législatif alors il y a des textes
législatifs en ce moment qui sont
examinés au Parlement notamment le
projet de la immigration il arrive en
séance lundi à l'Assemblée quel texte à
votre préférence celui de l'Assemblée ou
celui qui a été durci par le Sénat bah
il faudrait moi je je suis pas moi le
gouvernementin c'est au parlementaires
de de décider on sait que le Sénat a
fait sur ces sujets un travail
considérable depuis des années et tout
le monde rend hommage notamment à
l'exceptionnelle qualité des
investigations qui ont été conduites par
François Noël buffet le président de la
commission des Lois du Sénat euh et et
moi je considère que une partie des
propositions faites par François so Noël
buffet notamment pour faciliter
l'éloignement des étrangers en situation
irrégulière ou de ceux dont la présence
en France constitue une menace pour
l'ordre public je considère qu'une
partie de ces propositions ont été
reprises dans le texte de Gérald armanin
et c'est la raison pour laquelle parce
que moi j'ai été secrétaire général du
ministère de l'Immigration vous l'avez
rappelé donc j'ai eu sous mon autorité
les fonctionnaires des préfectures qui
gère les bureaux des étrangers c'est un
travail qui est particulièrement
difficile c'est un travail qui est
passionnant parce que on fait des
rencontres si jeose dire et on on est
confronté à des parcours de vie qui sont
compliqués dont certains parfois sont
dramatiques mais c'est un travail qui
est difficile et on a besoin d'une
législation efficace on n pas besoin
d'une législation qui permet à
l'étranger en situation irrégulière de
revenir tous les 6 mois en préfecture
sous un motif différent pour formuler
une nouvelle demande de titre de séjour
ça ne trp personne en tout cas ça trompe
ni les préfets ni les personnels des des
bureaux des étrangers et et donc je sais
que le Sénat s'est déclaré favorable à
ce qu'on a appelé l'examen à 360 degr
c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'un étranger
vient en préfecture il faut que on
puisse examiner sa situation sous tous
les angles de manière à ce qu'on prenne
une décision qui soit définitive ou
quasi
définitive et je trouve que c'est une
excellente chose d'ailleurs dans le
rapport il y a une proposition alors
elle ne fait pas consensus entre nous
avec Monsieur Evin mais il y a une
proposition qui consistait à subordonner
le renouvellement de laame au fait que
l'étranger qui bénéficie d'une aide
d'État donc financé par l'ensemble des
contribuables résidents en France
apporte la preuve qu'il a effectué une
démarche en préfecture c'est-à-dire
qu'il est sorti d'une clandestinité
totale qu'il a accepté que son dossier
soit examiné par le la préfecture
compétente bon et et ensuite si le
préfet prend un refus F de séjour ben au
moins on a la preuve que l'étranger a vu
sa situation examiner donc moi j'avais
proposé que le renouvellement de l'aide
médical d'État soit subordonné à la
production par l'étranger d'un refus de
séjour de plus de 3 mois parce qu'il
faut garder le délai de carence et et de
moins de 6 mois monsieur Evin ne l'a
pas pas donné son accord donc cette
proposition figure dans le rapport mais
elle apparaît comme faisant l'objet d'un
disensus un dernier mot parce qu'il y a
un autre texte qui qui est examiné en ce
moment au Parlement un texte des
républicains une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle pour élargir le champ
du référendum pour pas mettre un
référendum sur l'immigration et et pour
demander la primauté du droit national
sur le droit européen est-ce que c'est
une bonne chose que leslr essaent de
faire passer ce texte je dis essaye
parce que il y a eu un échec hier à
l'Assemblée où l'examen n'est même pas
aller jusqu'au bout et ça risque d'être
compliqué au Sénat avec les centristes
ouais alors écoutez ce texte je le
connais bien parce que j'ai dirigé la
campagne de Valérie pcrè et dans le
cadre de cette campagne c'est nous avons
nous avons proposé ce texte alors
ensuite il a été repris après l'échec de
Valérie pcrz il a été repris
par Monsieur l'arrivé par Guillaume
l'arrivé et par le parti des
républicains Bruno rotaillot le connaît
très bien ce texte que nous avions
élaboré pendant la campagne parce que
nous en avons discuté à plusieurs
reprises et et je lui avais fait
rencontrer un des plus éminents juristes
qui nous a aidé à rédiger cette partie-
làà alors quelle est ma philosophie
là-dessus je vais pas renier ce que ce
que j'ai fait en étant parfaitement
documenté cette fois-ci pendant la
campagne de de de Valérie pcrè euh de
quoi avons-nous besoin d'abord nous
avons besoin d'une révision de la
Constitution pour instaurer des quotas
parce que on instaurera de vrais quotas
des quotas efficaces notamment pour
maîtriser l'immigration familiale qu'en
révisant la Constitution mais ça on peut
réviser la Constitution selon les
procédures de l'article 89 je crois sans
aller au référendum sur l'article 11
alors ensuite ite ensuite se pose la
question de de savoir si même en ayant
révisé la Constitution on risque pas de
se heurter à des difficultés liées à la
jurisprudence des cours européennes
puisque je le
rappelle dans le traité de Lisbonne dans
un appendice du traité de Lisbonne je
crois que c'est l'annexe 17 on proclame
la supériorité du droit européen sur
tous les droits nationaux y compris les
droits constitutionnels alors il y a un
concept qui est le concept d'identité
constitutionnelle qui a été dégagé par
le Conseil constitutionnel en France et
on peut s'appuyer comme nous l'avons
fait pendant la campagne de Valérie pcrè
et comme le fait la proposition de l'olr
pour essayer de poser des limites à
l'interprétation va plutôt poser des
limites à la jurisprudence EUR un
dernier mot parce que pendant la la
campagne les centristes soutenaient
Valéri pcres or aujourd'hui il rejette
ses propositions est-ce discuté à
l'époque avec Hervé Marseille ah ben moi
j'en avais discuté pendant la campagne
présidentielle je voyais assez
régulièrement Jean-Christophe Lagarde
qui était le président de l'UDI et en
général je le voyais avec Hervé
Marseille donc lorsque nous avons dû
finaliser c'était je crois début mars ou
courant mars lorsque nous avons dû
finaliser notre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle j'ai consulté
Jean-Christophe Lagarde sur ce point
très précis et il m'a donné son accord
était l'ancien président du voilà il m'a
donné son accord c'est pour ça que
Valérie pcrè a pu faire une conférence
de presse à laquelle assistait
d'ailleurs
bonorotillot et HERV Marseille aussi
alors ça je m'en souviens pas et ce qui
est vrai c'est que pendant la campagne
présidentielle il m'arrivait de déjeuner
avec Jean-Christophe Lagarde et avec
Hervé Marseille par contre au téléphone
quand j'ai consulté Jean-Christophe
Lagarde je Hervé Marseille était pas en
ligne enfin je crois pas voilà vous
savez tout Mad merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin face
au club des territoires merci beaucoup